salut aujourd'hui je suis avec ma plus
jeune abonnés la plus jeune des plus
jeunes
andreas est la plus jeune abonnés de ma
chaîne est ce aussi la plus mignonne et
ouais ce que tu veux bien faire un tour
de magie pour moi sur la chaîne oui en
fait c'est juste pour remercier fabienne
va rester plusieurs jours ici à nous
apprendre plein plein plein de choses on
va le faire le tour de magie pour le
remercier c'est une recette spéciale gay
de jeu mais de peu attention regarde
tout ça au moins on va tout faire pour
jonathan un petit peu aléatoires mais le
couvert dessus tu fais pas de coupure de
caméras attention on fait ça
attention toujours précieux qu'est ce
qu'ils sont mais c'est trop
le repas de fabien pour ce soir est ce
qu'on va essayer de transformer un deux
trois mais c'est trop mignon maintenant
c'est un chiot il est trop beau t'es
trop brute et la vidéo la pub plus
d'états tiers de la plagne aux achats à
une petite fille n'était pas formidable
le champ des miettes on fait de plus en
plus avec ce monsieur empêché par
touches successives geste la main il ya
en dessous là comme tout est ce que moi
aussi je peux faire un tour tu sais dans
la magie on peut donner l'illusion de
faire des choses par exemple si je mets
la balle dans la main avec mon doigt en
appui enfin on peut croire 4 2 balles le
c6 si je sais pas et n'allons de la
bienvenue j'ai juste envie de faire un
mini tour de magie avec avec toi ce que
tu peux mettre la main comme ça
celle ci je la mets dans ma main à moi
celle ci dans ta main ferme bien le
point dessus du ferme fort fort fort
fort fort tu mets comme ça vas-y tu ne
bouge pas on regarde si je fais claque
la mienne elle disparaît tout de suite
et toi elle merci beaucoup d'avoir
regardez notre vidéo et nos tours de
magie si vous voulez faire plaisir et
andréanne n'hésitez pas à vous pouvez
laisser un si vous la trouvez mignonne
vous pouvez également vous et si vous
trouvez que j'exploite des enfants vous
pouvez dire tout commentaire
le mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an un rendez vous demain à 11
heures pour le prochain mondial blog
ciao